this is the last Hunger Games was the
last shot I imagine I mean we talked
about this a little bit when you did
comics I'm really excited about it but
you told me that it was extremely
emotional the last shot the last day
yeah it was weird it was true I mean we
didn't want to let go of each other me
Josh woody and Liam just kind of kept I
mean Josh and Liam and I got really
codependent towards rapping and we've
changed our call times and wouldn't ride
in the same car and wouldn't be anywhere
apart right so then we kept getting
anxiety about leaving the apartment and
then eventually we didn't and we all
just held each other and slaps oh you
slept together didn't like yeah we just
held onto each other forever right right
that's fantastic
it's woody and I no wages three-way
thing is not new I know
[Applause]
you just cheapen what you had with Andy
and I ya know it's awful
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Cohn
and clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography